[Música]
en Brasil el Tribunal Superior electoral
advirtió que serán castigados aquellos
que nieguen los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales entre tanto la
policía Busca desbloquear las
movilizaciones que han paralizado varias
vías troncales en algunas ciudades del
país por cuatro días consecutivos
el gobierno de Turquía afirmó que tanto
Suecia como Finlandia aún no cumplen con
los requerimientos en la lucha contra el
terrorismo para que le sea otorgada la
membresía de la otan de otra parte el
secretario general de esta Alianza
militar jensenberg afirmó que es hora de
darle la bienvenida a los dos países
nórdicos
y la UNESCO alertó que para el año 2050
un tercio de los glaciares a nivel
mundial se habrán derretido pese a estar
en zonas protegidas y a los esfuerzos
que ha hecho el hombre la razón el
rápido avance de la crisis climática
generada por el calentamiento global
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
a esta hora vamos a comenzar en Brasil
en donde el Tribunal Superior electoral
advirtió que serán castigados aquellos
que nieguen de manera a criminal el
resultado de las elecciones
presidenciales así lo indicó Alexandra
demorage el presidente del tse quien
además enfatizó en que las protestas que
se oponen a los resultados de la segunda
vuelta de las presidenciales serán
combatidos con la ley entre tanto la
policía continúa en sus intentos por
desbloquear las movilizaciones que han
interrumpido el tránsito vehicular en
diferentes ciudades del país en los
últimos cuatro días después de El
llamado de Jair bolsonaro dado el día de
ayer a desbloquear las vías
las elecciones terminaron el ganador se
investirá el 19 de diciembre y asumir el
cargo el 1 de enero de 2023 estos
democracia esto es alternancia de poder
Este es el estado republicano No hay
forma de impugnar un resultado
publicitado democráticamente los
responsables de estos movimientos
antidemocráticos serán investigados y
responsabilizados con base en la ley en
Colombia El senado de ese país aprobó la
reforma tributaria propuesta por el
presidente Gustavo Petro que busca
recaudar 4000 millones de dólares para
el año 2023 Durante los debates en el
legislativo Se tomaron algunas
decisiones significativas como la
eliminación de un artículo que buscaba
grabar algunas de las actividades de las
iglesias y también la exclusión de otros
que incluían por ejemplo el pan Entre
los alimentos Ultra procesados y que
debería recibir una carga tributaria
entre las propuestas que fueron
aprobadas está por ejemplo las regalías
de las petroleras que no deducibles y
también la creación de sobretasas a los
bancos a las compañías petroleras y a
las compañías hidroeléctricas está
pendiente también la aprobación en la
cámara de representantes cuyo debate
tiene lugar el día de hoy la reforma
tributaria fue el detonante de las
protestas antigobernamentales en el año
2021 porque arremetían principalmente
contra los ciudadanos de menos recursos
económicos
y pasamos ahora a Ecuador en donde los
reclusos de la penitenciaría del litoral
que es considerada la más violenta de
Ecuador recibieron con disparos y
granadas a cientos de policías y
militares que llegaron al lugar para
retomar el control de las instalaciones
de acuerdo con información del servicio
nacional de atención a personas privadas
de la libertad seis policías y dos
militares resultaron heridos en el
intento por recuperar el control de esta
cárcel que sirve a la ciudad de
Guayaquil que es la segunda ciudad de
importancia en Ecuador y hasta donde
fueron desplegados 2.600 uniformados
solamente para garantizar la seguridad
del penal y también para trabajar en la
reducción del hacinamiento y para hacer
algunas mejoras en la infraestructura
y en otros temas la asamblea general de
la ONU aprobó una nueva resolución para
exigir El Fin Del embargo de Estados
Unidos a Cuba una moción a la que
únicamente se opusieron Estados Unidos e
Israel desde hace tres décadas de manera
anual se hace este llamado por parte de
varios países en el marco de esta
asamblea de la ONU en esta ocasión la
moción contó con 185 votos a favor dos
en contra y dos abstenciones de Brasil y
de Ucrania desde el gobierno cubano
argumentaron que el embargo es un acto
deliberado de guerra económica contra la
isla por parte de Estados Unidos
dejen a Cuba vivir en paz
Cuba estaría mejor sin bloqueo
cada familia cubana viviría mejor sin
bloqueo
los estadounidenses
estarían mejor sin bloqueo a Cuba
Estados Unidos sería un mejor país sin
el bloqueo a Cuba el mundo sería mejor
sin bloqueo
el gobierno de Turquía dijo que tanto
Suecia como Finlandia no cumplen todavía
con las exigencias para poder hacer
parte de la otan para completar su
ingreso tanto Suecia como Finlandia
deben tener el aval de todos los países
miembros de esta Alianza pero el
secretario general del organismo oyenses
totalberg afirma que ya es el momento de
darles la bienvenida desde Estambul
nuestro corresponsal permanente allí
adrià Rocha nos da más información
el secretario general de la otan James
stolterberg ha presionado hoy desde
Estambul a Turquía para que levante el
Beto y acepte de una vez la entrada de
Finlandia y Suecia la otan algo que
lleva demorándose desde Primavera cuando
los dos países fueron aceptados en su
proceso de adhesión que aún no ha sido
ratificado todos los parlamentos de
todos los países miembros de la otan
tienen que ratificar la adhesión de un
nuevo país a la otan para que este sea
efectivo no lo han hecho dos son la o el
de Hungría de Víctor orbán y la Turquía
de resep type perdón control de
mercadillo que ya es el momento de que
estos dos países sean aceptados delante
del ministro de exteriores Turco mebluch
abusó lo que ha asegurado que no que
Suecia en Finlandia tienen que realizar
a un pasos que les quedan para que
Turquía levante su reto se refiere a la
deportación de ciudadanos kurdos
residentes en Suecia a los que Turquía
acusa de ser miembros de la guerrilla
curvo turca del que es considerada
terrorista por Turquía como también lo
es por la Unión Europea y los Estados
Unidos se espera que en la semana que
viene el martes de la semana que viene
el Primer Ministro sueco viaje a Turquía
para reunirse con erdogan para intentar
presionarle Además para que Turquía
levante este veto algo que no se prevé
según los expertos que vaya a ocurrir
muchos consideran que Turquía mantenderá
sobre todo hasta pasado este año y bien
entrado en el siguiente podría ser que
Turquía lo mantuviese hasta las
elecciones presidenciales en Turquía
programadas para junio de 2023
y Mientras tanto en Ucrania la
reanudación de la actividad portuaria
después de la reincorporación de Rusia
al acuerdo de exportación de granos y
también el llamado de las autoridades
prorusas en la ocupada región de gerson
para que abandonen la zona son algunos
de los hechos que marcaron esta jornada
allí en el este de Ucrania Rafael Pérez
nos cuenta más
vuelve la actividad a los puertos
ucranianos en medio de una jornada
movida los siete barcos partieron de los
muellescados en el mar Negro
transportando al menos
290.000 toneladas de productos agrícolas
el movimiento se sucede Un día después
de la reincorporación rusa al acuerdo de
granos sin embargo
Moscú aseguró que esto no es una
garantía para renovar su permanencia En
el pacto a partir del próximo 19 de
noviembre
ciertamente la discusión sobre la
prolongación del acuerdo de granos debe
continuar el período oficial aún no se
ha agotado ayer escucharon la
declaración del presidente pero para el
19 de noviembre debemos proporcionar una
evaluación general de la efectividad de
la implementación del acuerdo y cómo Se
realizaron los parámetros del trato
antes de decidir si continuamos
Mientras tanto en gerson el subdirector
de la Administración civil local hizo un
llamado a los residentes de la urbe a
huir para salvar sus vidas en el
contexto de una contraofensiva ucraniana
que tiene a las tropas invasoras en una
posición defensiva
en este momento estamos en las calles de
gerson y como pueden ver hay mucha gente
en la ciudad les pido amablemente con
todo lo que va a pasar y las decisiones
difíciles que se van a tomar protejan
sus vidas
otros de los hechos que marcaron la
jornada fue la desconexión de la planta
nuclear de saporiya de la red eléctrica
nacional lo que puede imposibilitar el
funcionamiento óptimo de sus generadores
y el intercambio de un centenar de
prisioneros de las partes en conflicto
como francas y positivas calificó la
nueva primera ministra de Italia Georgia
meloni las conversaciones con Los jefes
de estado y de gobierno de la Unión
Europea durante su primera visita a
Bruselas desde que asumió ese cargo
melón y sostuvo un encuentro con la jefe
de la comisión europea Úrsula fonder
Legend y la presidenta del parlamento
europeo Roberta metzola la jefa del
gobierno italiano discutió sobre temas
como la guerra en Ucrania la crisis
energética y la inmigración así como
algunos puntos importantes en materia
económica
bueno Y como lo indicaban los primeros
resultados Benjamín netanjago regresará
al poder tras la victoria de su partido
el partido licut y de sus aliados en las
elecciones legislativas en Israel
netanyahu y sus aliados de la derecha y
de algunos partidos religiosos o
tuvieron mayoría parlamentaria con 64
escaños de un total de 120 que tiene el
parlamento israelí de esta forma
netanyahu regresa a la escena política
pese a las investigaciones en su contra
por algunos casos de corrupción y tras
haber gobernado Israel por 15 años de
manera no consecutiva entre tanto cuatro
ciudadanos palestinos murieron en
algunos hechos de violencia en
cisjordania y en la zona de Jerusalén
este
[Aplausos]
en otros temas destacados del día el ex
Primer Ministro de Pakistán fue víctima
de un atentado el ataque ocurrió
mientras este protagonizaba una
concentración con sus partidarios el
hecho también dejó como saldo un muerto
y al menos nueve personas heridas
lo hice porque él estaba engañando al
público
trate de matarlo
y se lo mejor que pude
Esta es la confesión del hombre que
atentó contra la vida del ex Primer
Ministro pakistaní in rancán
el atentado se llevó a cabo mientras Kan
protagonizaba desde el pasado viernes lo
que denomina como una gran marcha contra
la injerencia extranjera horas después
del ataque el secretario general del
partido del político fue portador de un
mensaje suyo inram estaba advertido
y nos pidió que hiciéramos declaración
en su nombre dijo que tenía información
previa de la que no estábamos al tanto
de que estaba seguro de que tres
personas lo habían atacado y esas tres
personas son el Primer Ministro Chivas
el ministro del interior renasa y el
General de división faysal dijo que
tenía esta información desde antes y
sobre esta base estaba afirmando que el
ataque contra él fue realizado por ellos
su exigencia es que estos tres sean
removidos de sus cargos sino son
despedidos de sus cargos entonces habrá
protestas en todo el país
sin embargo uno de los acusados rechazó
de manera rotunda lo sucedido condenó el
hecho de disparar contra el presidente
del pti infrancamp con las palabras más
enérgicas le he pedido al ministro del
interior un informe inmediato sobre el
incidente rezo por la recuperación y la
salud del presidente del pti y otras
personas heridas
partidarios del ex Primer Ministro y ex
Astro del cricket salieron a las calles
a manifestarse contra la agresión
llegó al poder en las elecciones
generales de 2018 y posteriormente de
puesto en una moción de censura en abril
de este año el alega que fue un castigo
planeado en Washington por su visita
Moscú el primer día de la invasión rusa
Ucrania Pakistán tiene antecedentes de
violencia política el más reciente se
suma al asesinato de la ex primera
ministra de nacer voto en el año 2007
uno de los indicadores más visibles del
impacto de la crisis climática es el
derretimiento de los glaciares según la
UNESCO un tercio de Ellos están situados
en zonas protegidas y sin embargo habrán
desaparecido para el año 2050 se frene o
no el calentamiento global veamos
apenas unos meses después de que las
altas temperaturas bacheeran Records en
toda Europa y otras partes del mundo un
informe de la UNESCO confirma lo que
temen los científicos que investigan el
cambio climático un tercio de los
glaciares de los sitios del patrimonio
mundial habrán desaparecido en 2050
aunque reduzcamos las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero los glaciares se
están derritiendo en lugares
emblemáticos como los parques nacionales
de Yellowstone y Justin así como los
últimos glaciares que quedan en África
según el informe los glaciares del
patrimonio mundial pierden cada año 58
mil millones de toneladas de hielo Lo
que equivale al volumen total de agua
que utilizan Francia y España juntas
cada año el 50% de la humanidad depende
de forma directa o indirecta de los
glaciares como fuente de agua para el
uso doméstico la agricultura y la
hidroelectricidad los glaciares en el
hábitat natural de varias especies entre
ellas los osos polares que corren el
riesgo de extinguirse por hambre a
finales de siglo ya que la crisis
climática provoca la desaparición del
mar Ártico en otras partes del mundo
millones de personas están expuestas al
riesgo de inundaciones debido a la
subida del nivel del mar provocada por
el deshielo está rápida desaparición de
los glaciares se debe a un factor
principal el calentamiento global según
el estudio dos tercios de los glaciares
restantes del patrimonio mundial podrían
salvarse si el calentamiento global se
limita a 1,5 grados Celsius pero la ONU
ha advertido que las promesas climáticas
aún no son ni de lejos suficientes para
alcanzar este objetivo es todo por el
momento aquí en las noticias de France
24 siga con nosotros
[Música]